today the catch has been looking for a
new home for two months she lives in a
small apartment in the popular tights
back.now burr hood but the owner wants
her out he says he wants to use the
apartment himself as he's legally
entitled to do that means catch us to
find a new place within her artists
budget but demand for apartments is
staggering and so are the prices and
even on definition product him in here
the apartments I could consider renting
in here in Kreuzberg are gone within the
hour before you get to set up a viewing
they say sorry the apartment has been
removed from the ads or we've already
found a tenant amitabh catch links her
troubles to globalization that
multinational companies are sweeping up
property in Berlin and sending prices
soaring she's not alone I'm considering
moving abroad because I find it really
frustrating to have to leave my home
town because rents are no longer
affordable for original tenants for
those who have lived here over 30 years
I feel like all of our friends who have
kids can't find apartments and live in
studios with two children
Berlin's famous for its alternative arts
and culture scene poor but sexy went the
same this is part of the New Berlin
luxury apartments not for rent to buy
real estate companies Szabo guides
investors from around the world to
properties in Germany like the fritz
Tower micro apartments for Berlin's
digital and startup industries investors
from 13 countries have already bought in
mostly from Asia the company says they
have to focus on high-end flats rather
than social housing because the price of
land is soaring but they say Berlin is
still a relatively cheap place to live
the city is still affordable for
everyone and if you look at the
mortgages you have very low interest
rates and you can benefit from them for
long years so I believe that this will
continue yes
it's not just investors around 40,000
people are arriving in the city of 3.5
million every year or simply aren't
enough apartments to go around rents
have more than doubled in much of Berlin
over the last few years the city is now
playing catch-up it's pushing
state-owned companies to construct
thousands of affordable apartments while
curbing speculation sebastian shale says
berlin shouldn't become another london
or paris that's what's wrong wouldn't
the Charmin appeal of the city has a lot
to do with the mix of people the fact
that we don't have empty areas where the
super-rich live but a healthy mix in all
neighborhoods that's worth preserving
and he gets tried but Teresa ketch says
that mix is dying and fast globalization
has caught up to Berlin - she's joined a
local initiative to protect tenants
meanwhile she's still searching for a
new home
you